right folks my laptop makes it three
o'clock so I will make a start as ever I
I was looking over my slides a little
while ago re familiarizing myself
because I will shamelessly say these are
mostly slides that I've given before I
think most recently in NDC London last
year and I looked and thought there's no
way this is an hour's material which I
always do and then I always run over so
we'll see it's good to see so many
people here who are clearly fascinated
with dates and times or alternatively
you know this is clear statement of my
privilege and next time I will just go
all out and have a talk of let's all
come together and smash the patriarchy
and just see if I can get the same kind
of crowd anyway I want to be really
really clear about what this talk is
about and the secret is you already know
it because it's kind of in the title but
I have this slide many many many times
and I mean many times and before the end
of the session I'm going to get you all
to actually say it because what I never
want to hear again is oh just dates and
times and time zones are too hard so
I'll kind of just fudge it and not worry
about it the entire point of this talk
is that you can manage it I will be
talking you through my way of thinking
about dates and times it's not the only
way of thinking about it but it kind of
fits in nicely and fairly obviously it's
the one that I've built into my dotnet
date and time library no to him out of
interest how many of you are net
developers okay and how many not dotnet
developers okay but it's it's fine
because this isn't an Oda time talk I
will talk in terms of noter time types
but I'll explain what they are and these
days most platforms have a decent date
and time library but it may well not be
the one that's built into the platform
but the point is that I will go through
the concepts you will forget them and
that's fine because you learning the con
is not the point of the talk if showing
you the concepts helps persuade you that
they are learner bull then that's fine
though you've got so many great messages
to take away from so many great speakers
this week that there's no way you're
going to come away with a crystal clear
idea of date and time that will stick
what I hope will stick is this slide so
that next time you're working with date
and time not facing a date time problem
don't let it get that far
but next time you're doing anything with
dates and times you'll think ok now's
the time I will just dedicate a morning
or dedicate an afternoon to finding out
about date time things and you could re
watch this talk and you know follow
along the concepts you could read the
notice find user guide which again is
known as home centric but you know it
can all be applied elsewhere it can be
applied with them the.net date time and
date time offset should you wish for the
most part it's just less pleasant but
the point is you will be able to do it
so you then start thinking carefully and
it will take you longer to write your
code to start with and then you won't
have all those bugs that we're all aware
happen so this is kind of what we're
going to do a skit skip through that I
will say what we're not going to talk
about and notice I'm in particular does
not deal with relativity it does not
deal with leap seconds it does not deal
with multiple alternate clock
representations it deals with multiple
calendars which I'll come unto but these
are things that I believe are
sufficiently niche that we don't need
them in 99.9% of programming some people
do need them if you're writing code for
a GPS satellite then you're probably not
using node of time and you probably know
what you're doing it's sufficiently
specialist you're fine I should also
update this slide at some point because
I've had at least a few people ask me on
Twitter whether noda time is going to
handle Martian calendars no I have good
friends who are involved in the
standardization of a new JavaScript date
and time library you know as
so JavaScript itself and they work on
moment J s at other times and there was
a serious suggestion that well we've had
the current JavaScript date library for
twenty years so the new one should last
at least twenty years as well and maybe
we'll have colonized Mars by then so
maybe we should bake it in right now
it's like no like you are making life
harder for everyone else on the planet
for the sake of the very very few people
who might want that so we're this is the
typical reaction and yeah this is the
quality of slide drawing to expect I
don't have I was in Jennifer's talk
earlier on and they have fantastic memes
and gifts and stuff and this is what you
get with me I'm afraid sorry but the
point is it is all feasible and I want
you to feel calm that said I will tell
you a few horror stories and that's fine
most of which you won't need to deal
with because they're well in the past
and I will highlight some things that
are still difficult and the most code
will probably still ignore but at least
you'll know that you're ignoring it and
leaving that that problem for yourself
so just in case you'd already forgotten
you can learn this stuff it is feasible
I've another talk about text and numbers
and dates and times as humanity epic
fail how people have screwed up
everything basically I know a bit about
Unicode and I know it's enough to scare
me I know bits about floating-point
representations and they kind of scare
me too and my point is at least with
date and time it looks scary
it really doesn't have to be okay so we
will talk through some concepts and if
you've come from Java sort of pre
joda-time and pre jsr 3:10 Java dot time
or if you come from just plain net there
may seem to be an awful lot of concepts
here and there's a good reason for that
in the
way that if someone said I've got this
new programming language and it's only
got one numeric type it's got floating
points you know we would we would never
put up with a language like that for 20
years will be JavaScript but it would be
generally recognized to be a bit of a
problem and dates and times are far more
varied in fact than than just numbers so
this next slide is a list of concepts
that we have in no time and this was no
time to point one probably I could add
annual date and offset date and offset
time but they're kind of niche types and
you probably don't need to care about
them and you could probably get away
with thinking about them in terms of
these anyway so what is time I want you
to start thinking for yourself and I
can't do this for you about where you
use dates and times anything
chronological in your code base so I can
give you some examples your log messages
probably have time stamps of some kind
and you may have database records with
time stamps of when things were created
and if you do anything that is
scheduling you probably store some dates
and times that users have entered okay I
want you to keep as many of those
concrete examples in your head as you
can while we go through things and then
you can think oh yeah that's what this
one is as I show different examples so
the first sort of most fundamental idea
and it's fundamental in terms of there
are no humans involved because things
get tricky basically when people get
involved is the instant an instant in
time is something that is globally
recognized and this is we're not dealing
with relativity comes in so if I click
my finger and I'm on a phone call with
someone and they have an infinitely fast
phone connection then we can agree the
instant at which that click happens
regardless of where they are
and how fast they're moving and all
kinds of relativity stuff so an instant
in time has no concept of years months
days because I could be talking to
someone who uses a completely different
calendar system and is in a different
time zone and it's all impossible but an
instant the representation internally in
notice time and in almost everything is
there's some kind of epoch so we usually
use or UNIX folks always use the UNIX
epoch which is January the 1st 1970
midnight UTC not midnight at Greenwich
in 1970 I'll come on to that later on
there will be certain amounts of trivia
here just the scale but that's the UNIX
epoch dotnet uses one AD again at
January the first midnight and that's
perfectly good epoch it doesn't matter
at all because you can convert between
different representations trivially so
long as they have the same level of
precision you know to time now uses a
precision of nanoseconds which is
becoming sort of a reasonably industry
standard its fine-grained enough and
it's feasible enough you know as you
start getting into picoseconds or
whatever it starts getting a bit
expensive in terms of storage and things
so we use nanoseconds and anything else
that uses daño seconds regardless of
which epoch they're talking about we
could convert and obviously there are
limits to how far back and how far
forward you can go and chances are if
you're writing business code you just
will not care ok
unless you are storing dates beyond year
nine nine nine nine or nine nine nine
eight and years earlier than well
earlier than one ad could well be a
problem
in some cases and certainly is in dotnet
so you know it's worth being aware of
the precision of the systems you're
using and the range of values in the
system you're using
but you probably looked that up once and
say yep that's fine don't care anymore
but the important thing is to understand
that an instant has no calendar system
no time zone everyone can agree on it
this may be an appropriate
representation to at least think of your
data in four log entries there are other
options this is sort of a purist idea
for time stamps of all descriptions when
something happens is an instant you may
choose to store some more information as
well which I'll come on to but this
would be a good default first point
right so if we've got an instant that's
fine we can also have two instants in
time and if you're going to have two
instance then you can work out the
duration between them so durations our
time spans in net and they really are
absolutely equivalent concepts and a
duration has no concept of where it
started or finished so this duration
here assuming it really is the same
length of line and stupidly I didn't
just copy and paste because then it
would actually have been the same length
of line but if that if those two are the
same length then they are equal
durations compare that with an interval
where an interval is a start and an end
so it has a duration implicitly and
frankly if you're building your own date
and time library which I half recommend
and half don't it's probably a follow on
side project so Chris Bacon's write your
own CLI but you could represent this as
a start point and a duration or a start
point and an end point and they're all
isomorphic you can get it from any two
bits of that information you can get at
the third it's fine what we still don't
have is any notion of years months and
days or any notion of time zones so an
interval could be my system was down
between this instant and
instant how long was it down for it was
down for this duration of time that
duration of time will not be one month
one month is not a duration one second
is a duration or 30 24-hour days is a
duration whether you count one day as a
duration or not is kind of it's up for
grabs you can decide whether in your
terminology you will treat a day equals
24 hours
it comes in interesting when time zones
are involved okay everyone happy so far
good thank you
yes I do like a responsive audience so
just as a reminder you can do all of
this stuff
is anyone here feeling I'm already out
of my depth I I cannot understand
instance intervals and durations okay I
do sometimes give talks where the idea
is to tongue-in-cheek make it look like
I'm really smart and show you loads of
code to blow your mind this is not one
of those talks nothing here is terribly
hard which means if you don't understand
something that's because I screwed up
and the best thing you could do for
everyone in the room is shout out that
I've screwed up in the form of hey I
don't understand why he doesn't this
work or whatever okay it really is
simple my fault if you don't get it okay
next up and you can tell this was given
in January 2017 its calendar systems now
calendar systems are a way of human
beings screwing with programs and
calendar systems are entirely artificial
they are probably the aspect of human
life where religion affects coding the
most because almost every I'm not
kidding almost every calendar system you
come into contact with is started in
some religious form or other
so yeah we've got the Gregorian calendar
system and the Julian calendar system
Pope Gregory Pope Julius is
it's sorry not not spoke for the Julius
one but the the Gregorian calendar is
from Pope Gregory and if you look at the
the epoch in a grid the the time stamp
based system the epoch is when the
Gregorian calendar started so it's
deeply rooted in the Catholic Church
okay every time you're using a grid it's
related to the Catholic Catholic Church
it is the place where religion and code
come together
you've probably heard how many of you
have heard of the Julian calendar and
Gregorian calendar before okay keep your
hands up if you could tell me the
difference between them and I promise I
won't ask you but if you think you know
the difference okay relatively few it's
really easy the Julian calendar system
has easier leap years okay Julian
calendar system every four years is a
leap year in the Gregorian calendar
system that's true apart from when it's
also a multiple of a hundred so 1900
sorry and it is true again if it's a
multiple of four hundred so 1900 not a
leap year in the Gregorian calendar
system is in the Julian 2000 leap here
in both so basically you can remove a
couple of rules if you're building a
Julian calendar hardly anyone uses
Julian calendars apart from this odd
idea of a Julian day Julian day number
which is sort of a way of going back to
instant but instead of I've lost it
it takes an epoch that's a very very
long time ago and gives a elapsed time
in a floating-point number of days and
it's called the Julian day for reasons
that remain mysterious to me other than
I think the epoch is represented in the
Julian calendar system but could be
represented in any other current system
any instant in time once you've given it
a time zone can be represented in any
calendar if you treat it as a proleptic
calendar you don't need to know the
product take it just means sort of going
back in time the Gregorian calendar
started at different points in different
places in time
but we tend to think about it as going
back you know why why bother having the
idea of okay you're dealing with the
date you know January the first 1600 is
that in Britain or in Sweden or in
Norway because it'll give you different
results so when things are hey that's
that's not a good idea
in fact for 1600 it wouldn't but Kellet
systems various different ways I've
mentioned two of them there are multiple
other ones there are various Islamic
calendars and that gets complicated in
whole different ways someone's asking me
to implement the Hindu or one of the
Hindu calendar systems at the moment and
I got a bit of a surprise when I was
shortly about to release note of time
2.0 because someone asked me to
implement a new calendar system called
the wondrous or bahá'í calendar system
and my internal representation of things
in notice time is that you have a date
and it's got a year month in a day and I
like to be compact so I store the month
in four bits because 16 months is going
to be in a form right the bahá'í
calendar has 19 months okay that's final
I'll borrow a bit from somewhere else
and then we're good right oh well yes
sort of it's got 19 months of 19 days
and then every year there are a few days
that aren't in a month good luck with
that so you know we we fudge it and we
represent it slightly reasonably and
people who want to use that kind of
system can have something on top that
sort of gives them an honorable int for
the month of year or whatever so if you
ignore time zones you can imagine that
time line that we've had before
and break it up into years again ignore
time zones break it up into years break
each year up into months break each
month up in two days and you're good and
what you get from that is a date
a local date we call it in both no two
time
and in Java time not sure about other
frameworks that you saw of local as a
prefix confuses some people and you're
not gonna remember this now live but
when you're watching this again in you
know six months time or whatever this is
an important bit too no local just means
not associated with any time zone it
doesn't mean your local time zone to the
computer that you're using unlike for
example date time kind NoCal internet so
some people say that it should have been
called global instead of local because
it's it's not local to any one place
it's it's one of those things that's
hard to name unfortunately but basically
it's a date
it's a date as anyone would think about
it so 19th of June 1976 my date of my
birth that's a date in the Gregorian
calendar and some systems won't allow
you to specify a calendar and just
assume that you're using Gregorian and
for 99% of people that's probably okay
as well but be aware of whether or not
you can be aware at least have your eyes
open enough that you know there are
other calendar systems so once you've
got a date the next type is reasonably
obvious the next concept a time of day
and this is just a time of day this
doesn't have a date associated with it
examples of times that you might want a
local time my phone wakes me up at 6
o'clock it doesn't wake me up at 6
o'clock Europe London time it wakes me
up at 6 o'clock wherever I happen to be
that is a time of day a local time I
think it's time for a little bit of
trivia and I'll scare you a little about
the whole Julian Gregorian cutover so
how many days are in February I hear a
28 any advance on 28
she'll Scheldt 29 any advance on 29 is
there no one here from Sweden ha or at
least from Sweden in the 18th century
so in mostly the 18th century all of
Europe wanted to gradually change from
the Julian system to the Gregorian
system because the Gregorian system with
its extra rules is a really good
approximation for a full year as we go
around the Sun it's better than the
Julian thing is sort of like 22 over 7
is a pretty good approximation for pi
and you make things more complicated and
you get a better approximation
likewise for how long it takes for a
whole year so all of Europe wanted to
change from the Julian system to the
Gregorian system they all chose to do it
at different times but most places said
Jacque we will just skip a certain
number of days to get us onto the
Gregorian consistent and Sweden decided
that was too simple they were going to
have people heard about leap seconds
smearing at all yeah so so there's this
idea of there are leap seconds and so
that's like a minute with 61 seconds in
instead of 60 seconds and they're
unpredictable they're announced about 6
months in advance due to the earth
wobble and complicated things and rather
than everyone have to build their
software to cope with this there's this
idea of smearing the leap second so
instead of a clock that goes you know 58
59 60 0 1 2 it just makes everything a
little bit take a little bit longer
well Sweden sort of wanted to do this
with the Julian Gregorian cutover so
they said Jer what 1700 we will say
that's not a leap year and we just won't
have leap years for the next ten times
that there were beaten leek ears on
9 I can't remember and then by the end
of that time we won't have had to have
any skips we'll just have had a bunch of
28-day February's in a row that sounds
really simple unfortunately they got
distracted so they had a non-leap here
in 1700 when everyone else was having a
leap year and then they got into a war
so in 1704 and 17 808 they should have
been saying right no leap here no leap
year oh I've gone and done a leap year
again so by this point their plan was
completely out of whack so they decided
right okay let's just go back to being
the Julian calendar how can we do that
let's have a double leap here in 1712 so
February the 30th 1712 is one of I now
believe there are two occurrences of
February I think the Russian Revolution
decided it would do its own calendar
things as well and they had a February
8th but I don't know as much about that
if you think that the that Sweden is a
bit odd for doing that I'll tell you a
bit about when the UK changed at the
same time later on
Sweden eventually changed later in the
18th century so they they kept going as
the Julian calendar for a while
and then went into the Gregorian
calendar I believe that this actually
did have an historical effect at one
point where I think it was Russia and
some other country we're going to have a
battle and they'd sort of agreed what
date it was going to be but they didn't
bother say in the calendar system and so
one army turned up over a week before
the other say it's like the Mars rover
all over again
ok back to more serious stuff so we have
local time what do you get if you put a
local date on a local time together you
get a local date time and that's what
most watches will show if they show a
date they won't bother telling you what
timezone it is and you adjust it or at
least you old-fashioned watches the kind
I still wear
yeah you have to adjust it accordingly
if you're on a flight that's really
simple doesn't know about time zones
okay now we come to time zones and this
is where you might be thinking this is
where it gets painful if you're precise
in your thoughts it's not too bad so a
time zone is effectively a function from
time or instant to your local time local
date time and what you see is that when
you spring forward your local time jumps
by an hour and then when you fall back
it comes down by an hour you could also
draw this as another graph which is
mostly flat so if you have the offset
from UTC and UTC is not strictly a time
zone but you can think of it as a time
zone
anyone who sang or UTC is not a time
zone they're being pedantic for the sake
of it you can just ignore them seriously
there is no there may be some niche
applications where it's worth thinking
about UTC not as a time zone but for the
most part it's fine so it's it's just a
zero point it happens to be the zero
point that the UK observes during winter
time at the moment but it's just an
arbitrary offset that everything else
can be relative to so instead of this
diagonal graph you could imagine a graph
that's sort of horizontal so the UK
would be on 0 most of the time and then
would jump up to one in summertime and
then jump down to zero Oslo would be one
for most of the time and then jump up to
two for summertime jump down to one one
important thing to understand is that
it's not always just a matter of jump an
hour forward an hour backward sometimes
things can jump by more or less than an
hour and you might have
you know maybe Oslo decides hey this
bricks it thing sounded like a good idea
we're going to join the UK timezone if
you don't laugh you cry so in that case
they they could have sign that started
off at one and then went up to two and
then went down to one and then drop down
to zero and went you know between one
and zero and this does happen in real
life
rules change not just in terms of when
things happen but whole offsets change
quite significantly I'll give another
bit of trivia example Samoa ask anyone
next time you meet someone from Samoa as
I'm sure we always do ask them what they
were doing in in 2011 on December the
30th and whatever they say you can say
you lie they didn't do anything on
December 30th because there's Samoa
timezone went you'll have to imagine
that this is a really small scale or big
scale I can never remember which way
around it is so they went something like
- thirteen - thirteen - thirteen plus 11
plus 11 plus 11 it may have been
something slightly different to that but
it was definitely a gap of 24 hours at
midnight at the end of December 29th
2011 in Samoa it went from December 29th
to December 31st they just skipped the
whole of December 30th so never assumed
that that things only change by an hour
and also never assumed that daylight
saving time is always positive or always
an hour and this has become very real
quite recently since I last gave this
talk I think so this is the simple form
is just the offset or the mapping from
time to local time another way you can
look at it is to consider a standard
time notion and a savings so
example the UK at the moment always has
a standard time of zero and her savings
of zero in the winter and one in the
summer okay and you add savings and
standard together and you get what we
call the wall offset you know the the
overall offset from UTC something like
California would be minus eight as the
standard and then one as savings and
most places have zero or one as savings
depending on whether they're in summer
or winter time Ireland at the moment if
you look at the legislation and most of
the the iana time zone database is based
on legislation
Ayana says that since I think it's about
2005 I can check it later if anyone is
interested Ireland Standard Time is plus
one and it's saving time is zero or
minus one they have winter saving time
instead of summer saving time if you see
what I mean and this the assumption that
they like saving time is always positive
is so strong that Java at the moment is
not accepting that change they've got a
sort of backward compatible version of
the same data so that it will give
always a positive daylight saving time
but try to avoid making assumptions like
that Nepal for example has it's offset
most people are aware that the UTC
offset isn't always a whole number of
hours so India is always five thirty
five and a half hours from UTC at the
moment Nepal is five and three-quarter
hours but they were considering
introducing daylight saving time they
don't have DST at the moment but they
were considering introducing daylight
savings of an hour and a quarter well it
kind of makes sense it means for for
half the year
you're on UTC plus seven and that's
probably quite easy to work out with
other people
so try to avoid assumptions what I
haven't shown is the other aspect of a
time zone and the reason it's a zone is
it's meant to be a region on the earth
where everyone observes the same local
time always including back historically
okay so if you look in the time zone
database you will find lots and lots and
lots of time zones in America that
people would now call just central time
and the reason is you say well these two
places are in the same time zone aren't
they well they are now ish but if you
look back in 1975 or whatever they may
have had different local times so
strictly speaking they are different
time zones and quite how much energy you
want to pay to that put into that sort
of depends on your application if if you
need to know exactly when and where
someone was born it matters there are
plenty of people living today in time
zones that were different when they were
born and we'll going forward we expect
to have always the same offset okay time
zones are by far the most complicated
thing that we have looked at so far but
does it kind of make sense at the moment
okay I'll come on I'll come back to sort
of things not to say about time zones
later on but by the way the the parent
saying UTC isn't the time zone is
precisely because of this zone part it's
not like varies a region on earth that
is defined to be UTC everywhere
geographically has a time zone and it
may happen to coincide with GMT sorry
with UTC all the time but there's
nowhere that is defined to be each UTC
okay so fairly simply if you have a date
and time in a particular time zone that
is what I call a zone to date time
there's a tricky bit here this
particular zone date time that I've
shown is unambiguous and valid if I had
given I don't know the dates and they
don't matter too much but sometime in
October 2017 and I put 0 1 30 on the
watch it would have been ambiguous
because that local time would have
happened twice because that's what
happens when you fall back in a daylight
saving transition so you go you know 150
850 sorry 150 958 150 959 1 o'clock Bom
Bom Bom and so you you go over the the
1:30 twice and you can see that on the
graph this is why this graph is a useful
way of doing it as well as the the
horizontal one if you try to work out
what instant in time is represented by a
local date and time you can see that all
you need to do is go horizontally from
here you take your local date time and
you go horizontally and you say oh it
happened then and then if you try doing
it from here it didn't happen at all
1:30 in the morning
in some time in March whenever it was
wouldn't happen at all because we sprang
forward we went now 0 59 58 0 59 59 2
o'clock and other countries would do
different times so that's where
internally if you've got the idea of a
date and time and time zone you
absolutely want to have something saying
well if it's ambiguous which one did I
mean some libraries will do this by
storing an instant in time and maybe a
calendar system others will store the
time zone and the the local date and
time and the UTC offset and it's all
equivalent a lot of these things you can
represent in multiple different ways
time for the next reminder
hopefully by now this is sinking in if
nothing else is I don't care if nothing
else is so long as next time I'm here
people say GOI I went away and studied
that and it made sense and I was able to
use it that will be a win for me okay
sometimes you don't have a time zone
what you have is an offset instead o ISO
ISO 8601 is this sort of format and
beware of people who say oh I'm storing
something in UTC format it's like what
do you mean because UTC isn't a format
do you mean you've converted some other
form into an instant and you're
representing that instant and you're
using a textual representation which is
ISO because at that point you are
formatting if you're taking a value and
representing it as text that is
formatting so ISO 8601 is a format UTC
is not so anytime anyone asks you says
let's store it in UTC format ask them
exactly what they mean this is ISO 8601
format and here this bit is the zone
indicator according to ISO this is not a
time zone they screwed up this is an
offset very very different if someone
tells you this offset you do not know
and you say they've read this from their
watch and their watches time zone aware
you do not know what the time will be 1
minute later because an offset is not a
time zone there can be multiple time
zones all observing the same offset at
the same instant but a second later they
can have different offsets because
different countries do things at
different times does that make sense
this can be useful I mentioned before
that an instant was a good way of
representing a time stamp so things like
log entries
it can be useful to include an offset as
well it sort of depends whether whether
something notionally happened at a place
or not so if if you're recording people
going through a gate somewhere then that
probably makes sense you don't really
care about the time zone there because
you don't care what the local time was
going to be two minutes later but it
might be interesting to know what the
local time was when it's actually
occurred and you also might want to know
a total ordering across you know the
gate for the system over here and the
gate for a system in a different country
so you you want to be able to convert
everything and view them as incidents
but you also potentially want to know
what the local date and time was so
that's one example of using offset date
time the other is frankly when it would
be nicer to have timezone information
but we just don't so this this format is
very very common within protocols
headers and whatnot and in fact the
zoned date/time that we have before I
haven't said what the time zone is you
know in this case it from the IANA time
zone database it would be Europe /
London the Windows database time zone
database uses bizarre IDs it would be
something like British Standard Time and
it would still say British Standard Time
even if it were in June when we would be
using British summer time because
windows time zone IDs suck basically but
there is no UI so has this nice text
format for representing an off set date
time but there is nothing for
standardized for zone dates dates and
times and that's partly because the
Ayana time zone database is as close to
a standard time zone database as we have
but it's not really standardized in a
format formal way there's no ISO
specification for it it's kind of a
best-effort
effort from a lot of people okay so I
think now we've covered ignoring offset
dates and offset times and things we've
covered all the different ways that you
could represent the out now so you could
have it as an instant you could have it
as an offset date time you might want to
ignore the time entirely and just have a
local date you might want to ignore the
date in Thailand just have a local time
you know 342 p.m. you might want to
include the whole time zone 3:42 p.m. in
Osseo europe / oslo with an offset of
plus one just in case things happen and
sorry plus two at the moment etc period
is a different kind of concept period is
closer to duration but much more
complicated because humans have gone in
and screwed things up as always so
whereas a duration is between two points
in time and duration interval sorry
arithmetic is really really simple
if you have a duration of three hours
and a duration of two hours and you add
them together that's five hours and you
could do that by also looking at
intervals and it would all work nicely
duration arithmetic is simple period
arithmetic really really isn't it's
calendar arithmetic and different people
will have different ideas of right
results and that should make you nervous
as programmers to start with okay how do
you find out if someone is 18 years old
you know you want to know whether they
can vote in an election and the law says
they can vote if they're 18 years old
okay the elections on February 28th in a
non-leap year can someone who was born
on February 29th vote do they celebrate
their birthday on February 28th or March
the first site that's a judgment call
you could say they can vote if their
birthday plus 18 years
is before before or equal to the date or
you could say take the date and subtract
18 years and that becomes your sort of
cutoff point and those two both of which
sound entirely reasonable give you
different answers yay the good thing is
if you can persuade your product manager
or your client or whoever it is that hey
this is something they should really
think about yeah that it doesn't have an
obvious right answer but be that they
need to give you the answer they want
once they've done that it's actually
reasonably simple even if you've got a
framework that only supports the kind of
arithmetic you don't want so I truncate
so no time will if you add one month to
January thirtieth it will give you
February 29 29th other frameworks may
give you marks the first instead and if
you're aware of that as a possible
pitfall you can handle it okay I promise
you you can handle it and you know how
you can prove that you handle it you
write tests I'll talk briefly about
testing later on that's all the concepts
okay
has everyone basically follow along
followed along with an occasional sort
of old time zones are difficult yeah if
you can understand those concepts and if
you can understand how that means that
having date time date time offset and
time span as the only types available is
not good enough so how do I represent a
time of day
oh I'll use a time span what does that
time span mean oh it's it's the number
of elapsed hours since midnight well
it's probably not really cuz if there
was a daylight saving transition it
could be eight hours elapsed since
midnight but it's still nine o'clock in
the morning so it's a sort of Oh logical
if you ignore time zones well why don't
we have a time type for that so we have
lots of types in no time
and I'd advise you to think in terms of
lots of types even if you can't
represent them using
I I'm a realist I know that not
everyone's going to start using Notre
Dame if you have to use system date time
system date time offset or whatever
you've got in the language of your
choice you can still use these concepts
and put a comment saying yeah this is
actually a zone date/time and I will
keep the time zone in a different field
if I if I have to etc put things in
variable names if you have system date
time can be UTC or local or unspecified
where unspecified is the equipment of
local date/time local is sort of the
equipment of zone date/time with a time
zone which is the local time zone the
system default time zone and UTC
date/time is sort of equivalent to an
instant ish but because they're all
stored in one type it gets a bit screwy
but if you give your variables names
that say UTC in them and you validate
that things really are UTC you can avoid
an awful lot of problems so basically
there's there's something difficult that
I want you to do next time you run into
time zone and and date/time things at
all and that's I really quite like you
to think now we're used to sort of
saying don't make me think oh the a good
API doesn't make me think everything's
just obvious well no not necessarily no
time is specifically designed to make
you think it makes you make decisions
because it can't make you fall to make
those decisions for you
the idea is you make the decision and we
handle making it easy to represent that
decision in code so think about what you
need to store and in order to do so
think about where the data came from so
if someone says I want to schedule a
calendar event at nine o'clock on June
the 20th in New York it's a really good
idea to store that information
okay I'll come in - no I think I've
removed the slide saying what the myths
are but you will hear people saying only
ever store UTC and that's okay in some
cases but it's not always the right
thing you can very rarely go wrong if
you store the information you were given
so don't make stuff up and don't remove
information you can derive information
so if you store oh the user asked me to
create an event representing New York 9
o'clock in the morning in 2020 and you
know what I want to be able to compare
events wherever they occur in the world
so that I know which happens first
so I'll convert it to UTC as well have
an instant and I'll store that alongside
but that's only derive data okay I
haven't lost anything I haven't made
anything up I've just derived it that's
a good idea for storage you should be
aware and I see various people trying to
use no to time and doing far more than
they need to which is my fault for not
making it clear what they could do they
convert from a local time to a zone to
date time and back again
and back again and back again and
sometimes you need to do conversions in
order to arithmetic but you need to be
aware that every time you say what is
this local date time in this time zone
that can go wrong because it might be
one of these skipped ones it might be
one of these ambiguous ones so just like
I strongly recommend that you don't do
any more string conversions that you
need to than you need to don't do any
more conversions between local and zoned
than you need to be aware of different
calendars and cultures you probably only
need the gregorian calendar system but
it's worth being aware of and choose
good texture representations where for
for anything that might be read by
people in multiple different cultures
if your target is developers ISO 8601 is
your friend that's this one it's
completely clear that the year comes
first okay
do not write in this case it wouldn't be
too bad but do not write 10 / 1/2 n T 17
because we don't know whether that's
January or October
even if currently the only people who
have read it are in the u.s. don't use
the US format even if only currently
people who are in Sweden or Norway or
the UK will use it
don't use that format for developers who
are really I think it's reasonable to
expect developers to be able to
understand this use this format for
anyone else try to make sure that you
can get what their natural format is or
maybe use a representation as Jennifer
was saying before in her talk if you're
going to arrange a calendar event with
someone say you know Wednesday or
Tuesday June the 19th 2019 and if you
put that text in there that's awful for
machines to parse ok anyone who designs
a protocol like Adam had an awful state
representation in they don't use
anything culture specific in machine
possible text but do use culture
specific things for people because
that's what they understand people
machines different things okay think
where your text is going i do sometimes
wonder whether it'd be interesting to
have a programming language that had two
different string types one is people
string and one is machine string and it
would always you would get machine
readable but probably also developer
readable strings this way and people
readable strings this way and finally
that the tip I hate date/time now
slightly more than I hate date/time got
UTC now yeah almost never use date/time
now if for non dotnet developers that
gives you the system local
it's good if you're just writing
something and you're printing out the
current time on this machine and you
don't care about that value being
represented anything more than the
current session but otherwise it's a bad
idea but having these static properties
they shouldn't be properties anyway they
should be methods because they're
changing but having them aesthetic
things just kills testability think of
your database is a service so you make
it testable by putting an interface in
and using dependency injection the
system time the current time of the
world is a dependency so have a clock
representation notice time has I o'clock
and it has a separate nougat package of
notice I'm not testing with a fake clock
so you can say I would like to see what
my code will do on the y2k thing I'm not
so relevant now but if people had had
that 20 years ago it could have helped
who knows what will happen next be able
to test what will happen in all kinds of
different situations if you find
yourself having to change the system
clock there's something badly wrong
right so there are a few tricky bits to
be aware of you will sometimes have to
deal with incomplete information suppose
a user does say I want to schedule a
calendar event for 1:35 in the morning
at a particular on a particular day you
may not get to ask them well which of
those did you mean in particular it
would be quite odd if you ask them which
of them it meant and it's unambiguous
but it might become ambiguous just
skipping for the last sort of pseudo
bullet here and timezone rules change a
lot so last year I think there are about
10 different versions of the time zone
database
this year I think we're up to 2018 II
and I'm sure there will be more to come
so back in I think 2005 the u.s. changed
their rules for when daylight saving
time started and stopped it will happen
again probably in the u.s. it will
happen again for all my joking about
brexit I wouldn't be entirely surprised
if brexit changed what the UK did the UK
has had some interesting changes I said
I'd come back to the UNIX epoch people
will say the UNIX epoch is when it was
midnight in Greenwich in 1970 no it was
one o'clock in the morning because we
were observing BST at the time and BST
didn't stand for British summer time
it's the for British Standard Time which
was one hour ahead of UTC but without
any daylight savings and we were on that
for three years from 1968 to 1971 and
then we decided that was a bad idea
let's go back to you what we consider
normal we've also had British double say
like time savings time where it was two
hours ahead all kinds of interesting
stuff but the point is these things
change so if someone schedules that
thing for nine o'clock on say March 20th
in New York
if you've converted that to UTC you
might be wrong by the time it happens
the user said nine o'clock why did you
then wake me up at eight o'clock or
because the timezone rules changed I
don't care I said nine o'clock in 2020
what if they'd said 1:30 in the morning
on March 20th in New York site okay well
which 1:30 in the morning oh it doesn't
matter they're both to say you know that
there's only one of them because they
like saving time it's not a transition
well it might be by the time you get to
2020 so sometimes you won't have that
information and you should decide do not
let the system decide for you because
that's at best got a 50% chance of being
right whether you meant the earlier one
over later one and it could be that it
skipped instead of ambiguous so think
about those things if I don't have the
information however unlikely it may seem
what do I want to do
and I've mentioned working with poor
frameworks if you have to use java.util
calendar and java.util time zone and
java.util date you have my deep
sympathies notice time hasn't taken off
to nearly the extent that joda-time did
and that's because system dot date time
is confusingly usable it's quite easy to
think that your time code is okay
Annette if you're using date time even
if you're doing it wrong you might be
your code might be broken for two hours
a year and maybe you don't care about
that too much in Java it's so hard to
use Java util calendar and Java util
date properly that just everyone knows
it's awful so as soon as three at a time
came along it's like yeah I'll have some
of that please so you may be stuck using
poor frameworks but you don't have to be
stuck using poor concepts you can think
of the bigger concepts and represent all
the bits without having to write your
own framework without having to do all
kinds of stuff just be really really
clear in all your comments and
documentation and all your names I did
have a gotcha after all skipping to
record recommendations I hope you've got
the idea by now that put some time in
I'm not expecting you to remember this
but everything I said made sense to you
at the time so it can make sense to you
again when you've forgotten it later put
lots of tests in think document and
we're gonna say this together okay
because I'm a deep believer that if you
say something it will stick in your
memory right so ready ready all of it
just take away so take away next time
you work with date and time take a few
hours to grok it everything else is
filler thank you very much
[Applause]
next time we'll smash the patriarchy